je suis absolument honoré d'animer ce
moment politique extrêmement important
pour notre famille politique
[Applaudissements]
je suis très heureuse de vous retrouver
en ce dimanche matin avec nos amis et
nos élus de terrain
monsieur françois xavier bellamy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur olivier marleix qs
et monsieur bruno retailleau
[Applaudissements]
m
nous allons aborder ensemble la présence
de nos élus territoriaux locaux à
travers les territoires ainsi que nos
magnifiques fédération départementale
que vous vous fait vivre au quotidien
nous allons passer une heure afin
d'échanger ensemble avec nos présidents
de groupe nous allons accorder environ
15 minutes à chacun d'entre vous afin de
répondre à des questions essentielles et
vous est ainsi invité à utiliser si vous
le souhaitez le pupitre qui sera remis
sur scène je vous invite à faire du
bruit pour nos présidents
[Applaudissements]
olivier marroux l'ex vous avez des
maires de 2008 à 2017 mais également
vice président du conseil général
d'eure-et-loir de 2008 à 2011 élu
président de la fédération et l'ère
dorée loire depuis 2016 et bien sûr
député depuis 2012 est président de
groupe depuis 2022 je vous adresse ainsi
mes plus vives et sincères félicitations
pour cette élection
[Applaudissements]
notre famille politique vraie famille au
sens large prône aujourd'hui une refonte
de la droite selon vous comment les
jeunes république est un peu participé à
cette refondation de notre mouvement et
quelle place accorder à notre jeunesse
passionnée et amoureuse de notre pays
merci merci maman merci de votre accueil
c'est un immense plaisir de vous
retrouver pour la première fois pour moi
en tant que président du groupe des
républicains à l'assemblée nationale
mais j'espère la première fois je
participe à des universités d'été
puisque j'ai le bonheur d'avoir adhéré à
un parti politique ça s'appelait le rpr
à l'époque j'avais 15 ans et
j'étais responsable départemental des
jeunes 17 ans au département du cantal
chemin s'il ya des auvergnats dans la
salle
donc moi ces universités d'été c'est un
moment j'étais un moment important et
donc bravo merci de votre engagement ne
laissez jamais personne ne vous dira que
la politique ce n'est pas pour vous que
l'engagement dans la vie électifs c'est
ce sera bien mais plus tard
la politique c'est vraiment une affaire
de envie de servir une affaire de
passion pour la france et ça doit être
de plus fort que tout et merci d'être là
merci de nous communiquer votre votre
bel engagement et cette belle passion et
de lui donner envie malgré tout malgré
les mauvais résultats que nous avons pu
connaître en vide envie de continuer
or quelques mots on va les proposer à
propos un petit peu plus générale donc
on voudrait pas de m'éloigner un tout
petit peu du du sujet moi je pense qu'on
peut pas aborder l'avenir sans un
constat lucide sur les derniers mois que
nous avons que nous avons traversé le
consensus il savait dans l'est dans les
moments de grand traumatisme dans la vie
parfois on est tenté par le déni à
l'esprit humain est ainsi fait que pour
pour se préserver il fait comme s'il ne
s'était rien passé je rappelle qu'à
l'élection présidentielle nous avons
obtenu 4,70 pour cent des voix 4 78% mon
papa du score des écologistes on parle
pas du score d'un petit parti
souverainiste comme celui de monsieur
dupont aignan on parle du résultat d'une
famille politique qui apportait cinq
présidents de la république sous la vème
république
le fondateur le général de gaulle
georges pompidou valéry giscard
d'estaing jacques chirac et nicolas
sarkozy
on est bien que notre responsabilité
aujourd'hui elle est immense si on ne
peut pas faire comme s'il ne s'était
rien passé
alors heureusement on a des motifs
d'espoir on a eu un premier des
élections légistatives on nous annonçait
dans les sondages semaine après semaine
que nous ne serions plus cher à nyc
une trentaine de députés à l'assemblée
nationale
70 députés en réalité ont été élus sous
nos couleurs cher eric et présidait la
commission d'investiture 70 députés ont
été lus 62 sièges aujourd'hui dans nos
rangs et on est quand même passé de 4 78
ans totalise des voix de droite au
premier tour de l'élection législative
près de 14% des suffrages sur notre
famille politique
quel est le message que vous lui nous
nous exprimer les français dans ces deux
élections
devant les ont reconduits emmanuel
macron sans doute notre discours n'était
pas assez différencions assez lisible
quelles valeurs quartz sur nous qui
n'était pas portée ni par emmanuel
macron ni par marine le pen
visiblement ce n'était pas assez lisible
ils ont donc réélu emmanuel macron mais
par contre aux élections législatives il
lui a adressé à lui un message très
clair voir maintenant il va falloir que
tu écoutes on a réussi mais il va
falloir que tu écoutes que tu écoutes
les oppositions tu arrêtes de faire ton
petit chef et de décider tout seul dont
un conseil de défense secret et puis
vous les oppositions parce que c'est pas
une opposition qui a gagné vous les
oppositions on va avoir de quoi vous
êtes capables et donc cette nouvelle
configuration à l'assemblée nationale
elle nous oblige
à être une opposition qui veut être une
position utile utile pour les français
mais moi je n'ai pas peur d'être dans
l'opposition
différence de jusqu'à maintenant mais
lointain prédécesseur je n'ai aucune
aucune inspiration inventé sur le
titanic je vous rassure
je crois même d'ailleurs que dans le
seul parlementaire avoir fait un
signalement au procureur de la
république pour émettre des doutes sur
le financement de la campagne de macron
et c'est le lien qu'elle pouvait avoir
avec des décisions qu'il avait prises
dans le pour protéger ou pas certaines
de nos grandes entreprises je pense que
toute façon il n'ya pas deux il n'y a
pas de sujet de ce côté là non je n'ai
pas peur d'être dans l'opposition mais
nous serons toujours une position utile
pour les français une position d'intérêt
général et jamais nous laisseront aller
à mêler nos voir avec ceux qui spéculent
sur l'effondrement de notre pays
pour l'avenir puisque c'est comme ça
qu'ils nous qui nous intéresse
évidemment moi je crois que que tout est
possible pour 2027 pour ça que je suis
ici d'ailleurs sinon sincèrement je vais
faire autre chose que passer mes nuits à
l'assemblée nationale et c'est pour ça
évidemment que vous aussi vous aussi
vous êtes ici mais cet avenir il est il
est possible il est possible simplement
si je prends une faisons tirons les
conséquences du passé je crois qu'il ya
deux conditions deux conditions majeures
assez simple la première c ces deux
rassemblements aussi l'unité de notre
famille politique et la deuxième c'est
vous pour en parler à ne leur en a parlé
c'est le travail le travail pour rendre
plus évidente la vision que nous nous
portons pour la france
le rassemblement un petit mot quand même
on voudrait pas sauvage on a inventé
quelque chose d'assez étonnant
républicain
c'est chez les élections atteint on fait
des élections internes tous les ans vous
voyez ça dans aucun autre parti nous
c'est formidable leur évidemment mais
j'adore la démocratie interne je ne
voyais pas moins un dictateur potentiel
j'adore la democracia mais c'est un truc
génial à inventer tous les ans on fait
des élections des élections at un bon
parce que bien que les sélections
internes c'est qu'on est certain qu'à la
fin c'est toujours un air qui gagne
encore faut-il vérifier que même s'ils
sont bien de rang aux participants à
ceci près normalement sur
[Applaudissements]
sa personne à partir
mais on est sûr de gagner mais prenons
garde vous savez dans ces élections
internes ici je pourrais avoir un deux
trois ou quatre candidats j'ai connaît
tous bien ce sont tous des amis du
secret certains sont mêmes amis entre je
ne vivrai je ne dirais pas les dons du
fort
je crois qu'en réalité on a 95 96 97 %
de de conviction de conviction commun
les différences sont peut-être des
différences de sensibilité parce que on
n'a peut-être pas la même le même ordre
de priorité quand on est né dans un
département radical
quand on est né à nis dans l'arrière
pays niçois quand on est né dans le
bocage vendéen on n'a peut-être pas
exactement exactement là la même
sensibilité mais on a des convictions en
commun donc le message que je vous lance
ne sut rejoint pas les différences entre
nous je vous ferais
je vais vous faire un aveu est il vrai
un secret la veux c'est que je déteste
ce débat qui passionne les journalistes
ce débat sur les lignes je déteste ce
débat sur la ligne sur la lie déjà c'est
un truc un tout petit peu réducteur
c'était quoi la dîme de monsieur macron
quand il a gagné en 2000 en 2017 avec
des soutiens qui allait de robert hue à
alain madelin ou philippe de villiers
c'était quoi la ligne n'avait pas un
journaliste pour lui poser cette folie
poser cette question donc nous faisons
attention de ne pas de ne pas tomber
dans le piège évidemment c'est très je
comprend bien l'intérêt pour bien envie
qu'il ya souvent à essayer de résumer
notre pensée autour de grandes idées qui
seraient des clés de lecture nous
serions conservateur et libéral ou
patriotes et libéral
le conservateur mais sociale c'est très
facile mais on n'invente pas le slogan
avant d'avoir défini le produit donc
faisons attention à ne pas nous piéger
dans ce débat sur la ligne qui en
réalité n'intéresse pas grand monde dès
lors qu'on sait que nous avons un socle
de convictions en commun vous savez on
lisait un peu les mémoires du général de
gaulle général de gaulle je crois qu'il
avait il y avait deux grandes
convictions d'abord une certaine idée de
la france sur les premiers mots de ses
mémoires toute ma vie je me suis fait
une certaine idée de la france ce qu'est
ce que ça signifie ça veut dire la
priorité c'est l'intérêt national et
puis il avait une autre conviction une
autre phrase célèbre sait
il n'ya de querelle qui vaille que celle
de l'homme je crois qu'entre les deux
entre ces deux idées en réalité il y
avait la place pour un immense
pragmatisme donc faisons attention à ne
pas sombrer dans un débat sur la ligne
qui qui pourrait nous réduire qui
risquerait de nous réduire même s'il
faut encore j'en comprends bien la
nécessité puis n'oublions pas que les
français la seule question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est comment je boucler mes
fins de mois avec un salaire moyen de
1700 euros par mois c'est que moi ce que
je fais pour trouver un médecin comment
est ce que je vais financer les études
de mes enfants en croisant les doigts
pour que les trois n'ai pas envie de
faire des études supérieures si j'en ai
trois ce sens en réalité aujourd'hui la
réalité la question que se posent de
concitoyens et puis le
le secret que je voudrais vous livrer
leurs par rapport à ce débat sur la
ligne
je me suis amusé j'ai essayé de faire un
peu d'histoire après la dernière
élection présidentielle pour voir des
moments on gagne
en 2007 pour la dernière fois à vis des
moments mon père j'essaie de regarder
quelles étaient les qu'elle était là le
point commun toutes les fois où la
droite depuis qu'il ya des élections
dans notre pays a gagné l'élection
présidentielle
surmonter à 1848 la première élection
présidentielle au suffrage universel
direct nous dit ma sandrine rousseau
parce que c'est une élection uniquement
au suffrage universel masculin femmes il
a fallu le général de gaulle n'avait pas
droit de voter vous le savez
eh bien deux de 1848 à
1958 jusqu'à 2007 la droite n'a jamais
gagné que quand elle était capable de
rassembler toutes ses sensibilités de la
sensibilité d'une droite patriote
une droite on appelle souvent
bonapartiste
jusqu'à une droite plus plus modéré
qu'on appelle le centre droit se lit
vite entre nous il faut s'arrêter avant
bayrou parce que là c'est foutu mais
pour gagner l'élection présidentielle
jamais la droite n'a gagné autrement
qu'en rassemblant toutes ces droites et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que marine le
pen ne gagnera jamais l'élection
présidentielle parce qu'elle est
incapable de ce rassemblement
voilà pour la première le premier le
premier message ce devoir de ce devoir
de rassemblement et puis après le
rassemblement et bien nous avons
l'obligation de nous remettre au travail
pour de nouveau avoir un message visible
ici pour préhensibles incarner une offre
politique qui n'est pas celle qui n'est
pas celle des eaux votre regard de
l'état de notre pays après cinq ans de
quinquennat macron j'ai envie de dire
après
dix ans d'une espèce de corée jans
hollande macron ce qui est le plus
frappant en cette espèce de
déliquescence générale
c'est que le pays des fractures et de
partout c'est la guerre de tous contre
tous sert les riches contre les pauvres
les urbains chargeant l'udc contre
contre les ruraux c'est les viandards
contre contre les vegan il y a de la
fracturation partout et c'est pas le
résultat du hasard ce résultat stratégie
savamment entretenue construite par
emmanuel macron qui a tout fait pour un
petit d'arrêt il a réfléchi en banquier
d'affaires il a découpé le pays en parts
de marché il à hystériser au maximum d
opposition de gauche
dans les bras de mélenchon à côté des
oppositions de droite dans les bras de
marine le pen de l'autre et lille se
gardent la part de marché central de
l'as de la bien-pensance est en fait
aujourd'hui tous les partis politiques
dans notre pays quand on y réfléchit
bien c'est le disait daniel il ya
quelques instants tous les partis
politiques dans notre pays sauf un tous
les partis politiques aujourd'hui surf
sur ces divisions sont sur leurs parts
de marché dans ce segment je crois que
ce qui nous caractérise aujourd'hui
c'est que nous sommes le dernier la
dernière formation politique a osé
penser record à la nécessité d'une
cohésion nationale dans la collection
nationale c'est important pourquoi parce
que s'il ya pas de cohésion nationale
n'y a pas de nation mais la nation c'est
un tout où ça n'est rien et donc avec
notre combat ça doit être celui de
remettre de la cohésion nationale dans
notre pays vous savez je pense que dès
aujourd'hui les français savent qu
emmanuel macron ne sera plus candidat
c'est la constitution qu'il veut ne sera
plus candidat dans quatre ans qu un
trois et demi point d'un peu optimiste
et donc dès aujourd'hui parce qu'il
cherche à identifier ce que doit être
l'alternative les des électeurs de
droite y en a partout on a eu chez
marine le pen y avait chez zemmour il y
en a aussi beaucoup qui ont voté pour
emmanuel macron et donc à leur sujet de
devant je pense continuer à porter
fièrement ça nous a coûté cher parce
qu'on n'était pas si l'isi mais cette
idée de la cohésion nationale la
cohésion nationale c'est pas une idée
mièvre c'est pas
c'est pas le vivre ensemble dont on nous
a rebattu les oreilles pendant tant
d'années
la cohésion nationale c'est une c'est
quelque chose de très exigeant
il n'ya pas de cohésion nationale s'il
n'ya pas d'abord de travail partagé par
tous peut pas y avoir d'un côté la
france de ceux qui travaillent et de
l'autre côté la france ceux qui ne
travaillent pas c'est pour ça que dans
le texte pouvoir d'achat la rentrée nous
sommes battus pour retrouver l'esprit de
ce qui était les doigts sarkozy fillon
sur le travailler plus pour gagner plus
et nous avons obtenu gain de cause grâce
à notre travail en commun le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale c'est pour ça que
nous n'en tirons nous continuerons à
nous battre pour mettre à genoux mettre
en oeuvre cette idée que j'ai inscrits
dans le projet des républicains qui
était celle d'exiger datant de demander
que les allocataires du rsa est 15
heures d'activité soit l'intérêt général
soin de soi de formation mais on ne peut
pas imaginer de laisser comme ça des
français sur sur le bord de la route
c'est aussi une question de dignité pour
la cohésion nationale ceux de travail la
cohésion nationale c'est la défense de
notre industrie au moins une immense
différence entre nicolas sarkozy qui en
2004 sauval store en pensant en ayant à
l'esprit le sort des ouvriers de belfort
c'est exactement ce qu'il dit d'ailleurs
aux conseillers qui vient lui dire
laissons tomber l'entreprise dit
regarder le dossier en imaginant votre
père est à des ouvriers de cette
entreprise née toute la différence avec
emmanuel macron qui dix ans plus tard en
2014 laisse tomber alstom pour nous le
travail d'un ouvrier de belfort ça vaut
autant ça compte autant que ce que le
travail d'un banquier d'affaires
peut-être même plus
là la cohésion
la question nationale c'est aussi elle
suppose la justice sociale et fiscale on
peut pas avoir d'un côté des artisans
qui payent qui sont harassés de demande
de prélèvement sociaux de l'autre côté
ceux qui fraudent
de nombreux rapports parlementaires plus
de 30 milliards d'euros de fraude
sociale que fait le gouvernement c'est
pour ça que nous nous sommes battus avec
veut notamment quand je texte plfr sur
la carte vitale il faut mener ce combat
de la lutte contre la fraude sociale qui
n'est plus toléré par nos concitoyens et
ils ont raison la cohésion sociale
la justice fiscale justice il ya parmi
vous sans doute des enfants de des
enfants d'artisans ou de des patrons de
petites pmi si vous avez le moindre
retard de paiement de tva vous avez
droit vous avez administration fiscale
qui vous tombe sur le dos ça c'est la
règle pour les uns à côtés et puis pour
les autres mckinsey qui va à bercy
tranquillou négocier ces prix de
transfert et qui pendant dix ans ne
payent pas un euro d'impôt sur les
sociétés un qui au contraire mon offre
des marchés publics c'est une honte
absolue comment peut-il y avoir de la
cohésion nationale dans ces conditions
là la cohésion nationale c'est bien sûr
le respect de l'autorité cher eric il
est insupportable que d'un côté vous -
si en allant travailler on fait 10
kilomètres/heure d'excès de vitesse on
est immédiatement un point une amende sa
tombe et puis de l'autre côté il ya ceux
dans nos quartiers qui ont compris que
si je faisais une connerie c'est pas
grave jamais les policiers n'auraient le
droite façon de les poursuivre
de peur de mettre la vie de quelqu'un
d'autre quelqu'un en danger et donc ils
savent aujourd'hui la règle pour eux
c'est l'impunité et le savent tellement
qu'il se permet même de la violence à
l'égard des forces de l'ordre sans fin
dans notre pays chaque jour d'agression
pour les forces de l'ordre comment
peut-il y avoir de la cohésion nationale
quand on a un tel les ciels la cohésion
nationale c'est aussi évidemment
se battre pour
exiger qu'un étranger dans notre pays
respectent les lois de la république
c'est pour ça que j'aurais déposera la
proposition de loi que j'avais déposé
renault s'en souvient réformer notre
droit de l'expulsion ne pas avoir ces
procédures avec ses appels ses recours
en cassation qui font que le résultat
est magnifique l'imam il concerne je ne
suis pas un intime contrat remise à
l'intérieur de bruno tu me rassures
aujourd'hui temps de prendre la poudre
d'escampette il faut être beaucoup plus
ferme dans nos procédures d'expulsion la
cohésion nationale enfin elle suppose
que l'on
que l'on porté fièrement jean françois
xavier
un projet pour notre école pour que
notre école redevienne un endroit où on
apprend où on défend notre belle langue
française on est fiers de notre récit
national
et/ou croyons valorise notre magnifique
culture française sylvie puis
et puis enfin et puis enfin que j'en
termine là et puis enfin la cohésion
nationale elle suppose je suppose que
que l'on croit encore au cadre national
et je pense que s'il ya une différence
dans un petit sujet c'est une différence
majeure entre président de la république
et nous elle est peut-être là je suis
convaincu que président de la république
il est aujourd'hui
plus savez j'ai essayé de comprendre
athéna présidentielle faut faire preuve
d'honnêteté en politique ne savent à
quel c'est lé production d'emmanuel
macron je sais pas si vous avez réussi à
comprendre ce qu'était ses convictions
honnêtement il y en a une honnêtement il
y en a une je pense que c'est un
an sa vision mondialiste des choses en
sa vision du grand marché mondial je
pense qu'au fond ils croient plus en
europe par la france ils croient plus en
europe de la france sinon d'ailleurs il
ne nous paraît pas de souveraineté
européenne la souveraineté nationale à
la partie en peuple français
et nous livrons nous ne devons continuer
à croire à ce cadre national et y vais
devoir pour le président de la
république une épreuve dans l'est dans
les jours qui viennent dans les semaines
qui viennent sur cette question si
importante de l'énergie
pas besoin de faire de grands
dégagements sur le nucléaire si ce n'est
peut-être pour rappeler que nous sommes
le seul parti politique
le seul parti politique là encore si
j'étais honnête c'est par une belle
journée dans la salle avec les
communistes nous sommes les seuls à ne
jamais savoir céder à la mode sur
l'énergie nucléaire
ça mérite sa marque aux anneaux dispense
la mairie pu nous soyons fiers d'avoir
défendu contre vents et marées ce
patrimoine national bien donné dans les
jours qui viennent on va avoir cette
question de la crise de l'énergie qui
est au coeur des préoccupations des
français et moi je demande
solennellement au président de la
république de sortir de ce marché
européen de l'énergie qui est fou qui
lie le prix aujourd'hui le prix de
l'électricité avec celui du gaz le gaz
c'est 20 % d'énergie que nous consommons
en france aujourd'hui c'est 100 % du
prix de l'énergie de notre énergie à
cause d'une stupide règles européennes
qui régit le marché de gros les
espagnols en sont sortis les portugais
en sont sortis il est urgent que la
france en sorte si ce n'est pas l'état
français qui re fixes en fonction de ses
coûts de production
le prix dictés cité c'est aujourd'hui
monsieur poutine qui le fixent donc on a
encore un grand rendez vous pour
terminer sur sur le rang de notre
opposition puisque c'est la question le
thème qu'on m'avait donné avant michel
germaneau
bien le nôtre notre groupe à l'assemblée
nationale s'efforcera d'être toujours là
la boussole la boussole qui indique
l'intérêt national merci et par nos
mamans
il défend les couleurs des républiques à
l'anr semblait nationale mais tu me
plaît libérez
vous pouvez faire beaucoup plus fort
jamais possible
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous
effectivement comme vous dites monsieur
retailleau et président du groupe l'est
républicain au sénat
[Applaudissements]
monsieur météo vous avez des conseiller
général de 1988 à 2015 comprenant cinq
ans de présidence de ce conseil général
entre 2010 et 2015 vice président de la
région pays de la loire entre
1998 et 2004 puis président de cette
magnifique région entre 2015 et 2017 et
puis évidemment un rôle plus que
fondamental au parlement avec votre
mandat de député de la vendée entre 1994
et 1997 et puis finalement sénateur
depuis 2004 est naturellement président
du groupe ump puis l air depuis 2000 14
élus de terrain vous connaissez le rôle
fondamental et l'importance des élus qui
connaissent leur territoire leur
circonscription lors d'appartements et
leur région ainsi il me semble opportun
de vous demander comment un élu de
terrain peut créer du lien avec la
jeunesse du territoire et comment les
jeunes militants les républicains
peuvent faire vivre notre mouvement dans
dans notre magnifique france
merci manon d'abord je voudrais
remercier ceux qui sont avec moi
notamment olivier j'ai bu ses paroles je
le remercie d'avoir mis en exergue mes
racines vendéennes dont je suis fier je
bray clame
tout panache du panache de charette
combattu caen battu souvent battus
parfois abattus jamais
un salut amical bien sûr installer
amical à notre président du groupe
européen françois-xavier merci d'être
avec nous et puis un immense merci à
ceux qui sont ici et notamment annie
merci d'être présente
je veux pas citer tous les élus
simplement j'adresse un clin d'oeil
aussi bien eric qui est ici merci d'être
ici ce matin à aurélien à aurélien
je suis moi très fier que vous soyez
nombreux
ici dans ce que greniers saint jean sous
cette voûte de bois qui est que sorte de
vaisseau renversé bienvenue dans notre
région bienvenue à angers c'est un peu
grâce à stéphane que je vais quand même
remercier parce que cette idée a germé
il ya quelques mois
et puis quand on en avait parlé nous
avions tenu et j'ai tenu à ce que ce
grand rendez vous de rentrée soit placée
sous le signe de la jeunesse et guilhem
s'en souvient j'avais beaucoup possible
insisté pour que les conditions de ce
rendez vous jeunesse soient réunies et
il est je crois au delà de nos
espérances
voilà si je voulais que ce rendez vous
soit placée sous le signe de la jeunesse
ce n'est pas par je dise parce que je
vais peut être vous choquer je n'ai
jamais considéré que la jeunesse avec
plus de droits que par rapport aux
autres moi je n'ai jamais considéré que
la jeunesse était un continent à part ça
c'est de la démagogie en revanche en
revanche ce que j'ai toujours pensé
aujourd'hui comme hier et comme demain
ce que j'ai toujours pensé c'est que
quand vous devez quelque chose de
particulier parce que pour moi
aujourd'hui plus encore qu'hier vous
êtes la génération vous les jeunes
républicains vous êtes la génération
courage parce qu'il en faut du courage
aujourd'hui pour s'engager pour
s'engager en politique pour s'engager
dans un parti au moment où il y
attendent défiance vis-à-vis de la vie
politique et vis-à-vis aussi des parties
et
à ce nombre précis où cette défiance
pour être en décourager plus d'un en
refroidir plus d'un sur vous parce que
vous n'êtes pas détiennent parce que il
y a quelque chose qui brûle en vous
ce quelque chose c'est une flamme que
vous avez au fond de votre coeur
cette flamme aucune déception aucune
défaite aucun revers aucune trahison des
parvenus à l'éteindre vous devez la
conserver nous en avons besoin
parce que parfois quand il fait nuit
cette fin nous est utile
cette flamme
cette flamme c'est celle des convictions
préserver la déjà eu honte et je vous le
dis ici aucun des votes d'aucune de mes
convictions parce que j'ai toujours
considéré que la politique c'est les
collections
alors
il ya quand même une formalité avant qui
s'appelle une élection donc merci de
l'écouter ce que je dois vous dire c'est
que ce courage votre courage oblige et
nous oblige aussi avoir le courage de
vous dire la vérité
de vous dire les choses telles que nous
les pensons
vous m'aviez demandé ce rapport des élus
à l'agenaise m'aviez demandé est ce que
vraiment le sénat un peu comme
l'assemblée nationale avoir un rôle dans
la reconstruction de la droite
moi mon devoir ce matin c'est de vous
dire que bien sûr olivier pense la même
chose le parlement le sénat l'assemblée
nationale nous avons un rôle selon le
let important mais ce rôle il est
insuffisant et je vais vous dire
pourquoi d'abord peut-être vous dire
déjà pourquoi est ce que le rôle est
important avant même la configuration
politique que nous connaissons par le
vent cette majorité relative ou cette
majorité tout court que n'a pas emmanuel
macron nous au sénat très vite quand on
a vu se dessiner dès les premiers jours
dès les premières semaines du
quinquennat jupiter narcisse janus
à deux faces nous avons bâti au sénat un
contre-pouvoir qui soit solide je vous
en donner que deux exemples nous avons
fait dérailler au sénat le début du
quinquennat avec la commission denquête
donald à souvenez vous en
un autre exemple
un autre exemple qui m'est cher
parce que vous êtes la génération
digitale nous avons fait exploser aussi
au sénat et je m'en suis chargé
personnellement la loi 1 via qui
prétendait confié aux gammes une censure
privé la censure de votre liberté
d'expression
et puis maintenant
évidemment depuis qu'on a cette nouvelle
configuration parlementaire politique et
grâce à la bonne entente entre nos gros
grâce aussi au super président du groupe
de l'assemblée nationale et à d'autres
ententes avec olivier et bien je pense
que là ce rôle est accrue et ne vous
dites pas que c'est nous qui votons les
textes du gouvernement mac renoncé d'eux
qu'ils votent le texte regardez-le
encore un exemple sur le sanitaire ils
voulaient nous repasser ils voulaient
nous repasser le pass sanitaires on n'en
voulait pas tu souvient olivier et bien
re lisez le texte il était totalement
réécrit et sur le pouvoir d'achat on
avait des convictions 1 que le pouvoir
d'achat s'était pas l'état distributeur
de chèques parce que l'état s'est pas
mère teresa un jour il vous fait un
chèque mais le lendemain ou le
surlendemain il vous fait les poches
c'est ça l'endettement et
bien sûr que le pouvoir d'achat
le pouvoir d'achat c'est le travail et
nous avons effacé enfin les conséquences
des lecteurs des 35 heures j'écoutais
daniel faire tout à l'heure un parallèle
entre le niveau de vie des suisses et
des français qui étaient équivalents
dans les exposants 10 mai avec les
allemands pareil en 2000 même niveau de
vie vingt ans après 5000 euros de
différence la différence c'est nous les
35 heures et c'est eux ont augmenté
leurs mains ce travail pour créer de la
richesse donc le travail c'est le
pouvoir d'achat c'est le niveau de vie
est de même que la fraude à la sécurité
sociale nous l'avons combattu au sénat
mon cher philippe nous avions voté ce
texte déjà pour imposer une carte vitale
biométrique parce que il ya 6 millions 7
millions de cartes vitale biométrique en
france en plus ce qu'il y a de france
cherchez la différence c'est au moins 20
milliards de fraudes voilà ce que nous
avons fait
je voudrais terminer
sur ce point parce que olivier tu
parlais de rassemblement alors moi je
voudrais très clair sur ce terme
je pense que nous avons mises en oeuvre
et en pratique un mode horde que j'avais
à l'époque entendu dans la bouche de
laurent lors invoquer lorsqu'il s'était
présenté en 2010 est rassemblé sans se
renier rassembler sans se renier et bien
jamais venu à nous sommes reliés nous
nous sommes portés aux deux ans est en
première ligne de tous les combats au
moment du terrorisme contre
l'immigration massive contre l'islamisme
qui a voté l'interdiction du port clic
c'est au sénat c'est la droite
sénatoriale qui a voté l'interdiction
justement du voile sur les
accompagnatrices colère ou encore du
voile pendant les compétitions sportives
c'est le sénat et nous les avons voté
nous ne sommes pas relié
jamais nous sommes grenier n'est jamais
nous nous sommes divisés parce que quand
on porte les amis quand on porte une
autorité quand on porte une
responsabilité
notre devoir c'est aussi l'efficacité
c'est le résultat c'est le rassemblement
plutôt que de susciter des oppositions
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire dans
un premier temps alors bien sûr ce m il
n'est pas suffisant loin de là et je
veux pas minimiser le rôle du parlement
mais ce rôle il est presque secondaire
par rapport au parti je vais vous dire
pourquoi je sais que beaucoup
aujourd'hui théorise la fin des parties
et c'est vrai des parties vont mal et
c'est vrai le nôtre ne va pas bien
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que cela
se trompent parce qu'il faudra toujours
un parti déjà pour appuyer des groupes
parlementaires je n'ai jamais vu il est
parlement un grain de la sent un socle
cash flow 3000 chazel ça n'existe pas
vous mais moi dire c'est le retour du
père noël est parti vendait
l eau derrière devient tassement des
partis et deuxième élément si vous avez
des convictions si vous avez un cadre
idéologie si vous pensez le monde avec
une vision qui vous est propre personnel
singulière alors il faut aussi un parti
pour mettre en forme cette vision pour
lui donner du corps et c'est ce que nous
devons faire aujourd'hui avec un nouveau
parti pour une vraie droite bien sûr
l'encore si je me réfère ce que disait
tout à l'heure olivier ya un énorme
paradoxe aujourd'hui sur ce paradoxe et
toutes les études montrent que jamais
les français n'avaient été autant un
droit et pour autant jamais on a eu
aussi peu d'électeurs il ya quand même
un problème non alors tout change et
nous on ne devrait rien changer il faut
en tenir compte et je pense que si on
veut demain repartir rebâtir un grand
parti populaire notre adria bien il faut
retrouver une crédibilité parce que je
pense que si nous n'avons soirée deep il
a su nous n'aurons par là ne seront pas
audible et japon et jusqu'à présent et
je suis désolé je défende à
300 a
cédé yeux courbaient l'échiné c'est bien
l'ancien grenat
n'existe peut porter nos convictions
mais ce sont pas les morts qui feront la
différence
ce ne seront pas les moeurs qui font la
différence ce n'est pas le volume des
mots ce n'est pas non plus la force des
mots même si le verbe j'y crois mais
c'est demain des actes et comme les
français ne nous croient plus il faudra
leur donner des preuves et cette preuve
ce sera d'abord de changer de fond en
comble notre mouvement politique et
notamment et notamment pour que nos
adhérents se réapproprie se
réapproprient leur mouvement un adhérent
un militant ça n'est pas qu'un
distributeur de tas de tracts un
remplisseurs de salle ça n'est pas qu'un
conte leurs affiches vous savez je crois
profondément que la crise démocratique
française elle vient du fait que les
français désormais vote mais qu'ils
pensent ce qu'ils votent encore mais qui
pensent que leur vote en réalité
personne n'en tient qu'aux comme si il y
avait en france en france une démocratie
sans le peuple comme si en france la
majorité de gouverner plus ça c'est ma
conviction cette conviction qui vaut
pour la france on doit aussi la faire
valoir en interne et sur toutes les
grandes questions
regardez la grande question qui nous a
agité après l'élection présidentielle
est ce qu'on va faire du texte par texte
où est ce qu'on va aller dans une
position et demain est-ce qu'on va par
exemple voter le budget bien sûr que non
nous sommes dans l'opposition il ya eu
des voix 10 heures on aurait dû il faut
faire trancher désormais par une
démocratie directe pulsé grande question
pour quelle est la force de la
légitimité populaire
et puis je parlais d'une vraie droite je
pense qu'on est nombreux à la souhaiter
pourquoi je parle d'une vraie droite
bien sûr parce qu'à défaut droit je
pense que le maquereau nice met une
fausse droit je pense que le lepénisme
est une fausse bonne mais moi ce que je
ne veux pas c'est que
on se reconstruise mais qu'on soit une
droite qui se défausse
on ne serait alors qu'une droite qui
serait si j'ose dire un jour sur deux
sur ne cligne une droite à mi temps
c'est à dire une moitié droite les
français ne nous écoute plus parce
qu'ils ne savent plus qui nous sommes
ils ne savent plus où on se trouve et
voient leur dire fièrement que nous on
est de droite et qu'on ait la droite est
pas la droite à moitié pas la droite
habitants qu'on est complètement de
droite
et bien sûr
vous rebondir sur les propos d'olivier
j'aurais pu rebondir sur les propos de
françois xavier b tu t'es pas encore
exprimée pour rebondir sur les propos
d'olivier moi aussi même chose la
querelle des étiquettes elle est
terrible quand je dis il nous faut une
droite et qu'on soit de droite
complètement c'est pour moi la droite
c'est un tout la droite c'est un tout
parce que tout se tient parce que vous
n'aurez pas la liberté si vous n'avez
pas l'ordre et l'autorité le désordre
c'est la servitude parce que vous
n'aurez pas un système social qu'il faut
se préoccuper des fragilités des plus
vulnérables faits le handicap les
personnes âgées etc mais pour ça il nous
faut créer des richesses c'est tout un
peu même que l'identité juive en deroin
et je revendique voyait la vendée c'est
à des tout premiers départements sur
l'emploi et la vendée est le fier de ses
racines et bien l'identité mes amis
l'identité française
ce ne sont pas des valeurs qui nous en
faire c'est une scène qui nous permet de
faire mieux que nos frondaisons jusqu'au
ciel c'est ça que je pense et c'est très
bien aussi avec la dimension économique
j'en suis même le témoin au quotidien à
travers le réseau de pme de deux pays du
grand thouet sellal mittelstand ailleurs
français dans notre grand poète ailleurs
un petit peu aussi mais quand même c'est
un peu de chauvinisme et puis enfin et
puis enfin sur cette droite qui est un
tout elle est un tout notre droite à
nous parce que la france n est pas rien
parce que pour nous rien de ce qui est
français ne nous est étranger ni la
grandeur de notre culture jean françois
xavier ni la grandeur de notre
civilisation mais ni les valeurs des
perdants de la mondialisation
ni cette angoisse qui tenaille les
classes populaires angoisses du
déclassement économique et social mais
surtout aussi l' angoisse de la
dépossession des possessions identitaire
dépossession démocratique
comme je le disais il ya quelques
instants alors oui je veux cette droite
qui soit une droite courageuse qu'il
soit une droite nouveau à la reconquête
avec fous les jeunes parce que vous avez
ce courage de mener les combats à venir
parce qu'on a compté sur vous et puis
bien entendu je veux cette droite aussi
audacieuse oui on est tous là à dire
qu'il faut défricher deschamps nous au
ces gens nouveaux bien sûr que c'est
l'écologie j'ai des enfants et je sais
la sensibilité et l'écologie c'est un
monde habitable l'écologie c'est notre
patrimoine à nous de la droite
l'écologie est lead en tout cas le cadre
doctrinal est né à droite il faut
cultiver on peut plus au moment où le
mot qui s'invite dans nos assiettes on
peut plus rester les bras ballants moi
j'ai rien contre les gens qui mangent du
tofu c'est pas mon truc j'ai rien
fondamentalement et jamais je re
interdirait mans de manger du tofu mais
au moins qu'on blaise continuer à faire
des barbecues
si je le veux voilà et je vais même
et je vais même aggraver mon cas bien
sûr mais ce qui suit est intéressant
j'avais pas graver mon cas moi je pense
que c'est pas les hommes qui sont ans
évidemment c'est les femmes qui sont
fausses voilà donc devant cet islam
pardon non pas les slameurs gauchisme
l'écolo gauchistes d'ailleurs avec le
maire de grenoble on le voit bien tout
ça va de pair dans une nouvelle
idéologie
mais il faudra j'ai écrit un livre sur
l'écologie évidemment qu'il faut une
écologie humaine évidemment qu'il faut
une écologie de l'esthétique de la potée
la beauté d'un paysage ça nous touche on
va pas les défigurer et bien sûr qu'il
faut aussi une écologie de la raison qui
allie la science bien sûr qu'il faut
refonder l'école une école de la fierté
française où on célèbre nos héros et non
pas uniquement pour demande à la france
de s'excuser perpétuellement et sur le
numérique loew et averses est ce que
demain vous voulez vivre vos vies
virtuelles dans un univers créé par les
gars fiable aux états unis non on est
européen on est français de culture
française et pour conclure je vais être
encore plus court et pour conclure le
maréchal de lattre a eu cette belle
phrase bio en revenant d'une grande
bretagne il avait dit
frappé ses adversaires c'est bien
mais frapper l'imagination c'est encore
mieux mais c'est ce qu'on va devoir il
faut
il faut pas qu'on se contente de subir
le modèle je crois progressiste très
européiste des belle macro il va falloir
qu'on propose notre modèle de société
il faut pas on peut pas nous abandonner
ni aux facilités ni à la fatalité la
face à lille la facilité aux facilités
on doit poser l'exigence l'exigence du
travail qu'on peut pas nous vouloir la
valeur travail et pas travailler sur le
plan doctrinal quand même pour faire
tout un logiciel à cette facilité on
doit aussi opposé l'audace l'imagination
et puis la fatalité on la combat on doit
les combattre par l'espérance parce que
la france mes amis c'est ce combat qui
est toujours à recommencer contre la
fatalité contre le défaitisme et
n'oubliez jamais que dans l'histoire des
hommes la france est ce pays où
les plus grands chaos peuvent surgir les
plus beaux su so c'est la vérité
profonde je prends c'est la vérité
éternelle de ce que nous sommes alors
ici devant vous à angers nous allons
faire un serment jamais nous ne
laisserons tomber nos convictions parce
que jamais nous ne laisserons tomber la
france
il porte les couleurs des républicains
c'est mon petit bibi libellé télé
et
au
général attendus patrie
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
merci pour cette magnifique ambiance on
gc magnifique
françois-xavier bellamy si vous êtes
élue en 2008 dans la cité de versailles
en tant qu adjoint chargé de l'emploi de
la jeunesse et de l'enseignement
supérieur en 2019 vous êtes député
européen après avoir été tête de liste
conduisant ainsi la liste comprenant
nadine morano agnès evren ou encore
arnaud danjean de ce fait je crois qu'il
est très important de rappeler et vous
en êtes le symbole par excellence de
l'importance de la jeunesse dans notre
mouvement
par conséquent quel message souhaitez
vous faire passer à notre jeunesse et
par quel levier imaginez-vous le plus
grand mouvement politique jeunes de
france petit peu demain après cette
magnifique france de demain
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes je dois dire je dois dire que
vous êtes impressionnant c'est
incroyable de vous voir si nombreux ce
matin et c'est vraiment incroyable de
vous voir aussi nombreux pas seulement
après les défaites où les épisodes
électoraux difficile de l'an dernier pas
seulement après les épisodes électoraux
difficile des derniers des dernières
années mais c'est impressionnant de vous
voir si nombreux après la soirée d'hier
soir et quand on vous voit on sait comme
je ne lâcherai jamais rien
parce que je peux confirmer ce que
disait charles tout à l'heure on a fait
un débriefing avec nadine et michel je
sais 4la ce matin ce matin j'ai croisés
dans anges et des jeunes républicains a
garé à la recherche d'un café ce matin
être là c'est un signe de courage
quasiment héroïques et je voulais vous
en remercier et vous dire à quel point
et vous dire à quel point
à quel point c'est un bonheur de vous
retrouver comme comme chaque année à
quel point c'est un bonheur de partager
cette rentrée avec vous charles le
disait très bien
c'est vraiment un encouragement
magnifique de vous savoir la toujours
fidèle au rendez vous et je voudrais
dire un immense merci et un immense
bravo à killem à théo à charlotte à tout
le bureau national a que l'équipe des
jeunes républicains
à tristan ganivenq
vous avez organisé cet événement dont on
en parlait avec annie avec beaucoup
d'admiration dans un moment très
contraint avec la des moyens très
contraint et pourtant vous êtes au
rendez vous elle ce rendez vous là c'est
celui de la fidélité et nous savons que
ce rendez vous là vous ne manquerez
jamais alors ce matin je voulais
simplement partager trois message tout
simple avec vous c'est difficile de
passer après olivier et bruno je vais
essayer de faire simple et court mais
juste trois messages très simple pour
commencer cette année cette année qui va
être je crois extrêmement importante et
cette année qui va être je crois aussi
sans doute extrêmement difficile pour
notre pays tout entier parce que nous
allons sans aucun doute olivier tu
disais au devant de tension forte dans
un moment où notre pays n'a jamais été
aussi fracturé mon premier message tout
simple mais je sais que vous le partagez
déjà c ne vous laissez pas intimider
hier j'ai été marqué en parlant avec
vous du nombre d'entre vous qui m'avait
raconté les difficultés auxquelles ils
font face dans leur campus dans leurs
universités pour mener leurs activités
militantes pour inviter des intervenants
pour pouvoir tout simplement témoigner
de leurs convictions ne vous laissez pas
intimider il n'y a aucune raison que les
administrations de nos institutions
d'enseignement universitaire il n'y a
aucune raison que ceux qui prétendent
faire la loi sur les campus vous
interdise de dire ce en quoi vous croyez
ce à quoi vous pensez ne vous laissez
pas intimider même par la menace de la
violence et je pense par exemple à un
homme manssouri qui a été attaquée
violemment à grenoble je pense à tous
ceux qui l'an dernier
est peut-être je le dis ici à tous nos
amis journalistes ces fragments qu'on
n'en parle pas assez que dans notre pays
des élus que dans notre pays des élus
étudiants que dans notre pays des
candidats les gens qui se sont engagés
simplement pour défendre leurs
convictions dans un contexte
démocratique ait pu être qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs de notre parti politique ou
d'autres familles politiques et puis
être parfois un timide et parfois même
agressé parfois violentes et alors que
nous devrions dans une démocratie chérir
absolument la liberté d'expression et le
pluralisme ne vous laissez pas intimider
et vous avez le courage je le sais de
continuer à défendre vos convictions
même dans ce climat qui devient de plus
en plus difficile ne vous laissez pas
non plus intimidé par ceux qui vous
expliqueront avec des barrières de mots
que vous êtes coupable de penser ce que
vous pensez que vous êtes coupable de
croire ce en quoi vous croyez bruno et
olivier l'on dit mieux que moi nous
n'avons pas à rougir nous n'avons pas à
rougir devant les écologistes de
pacotille qui voudrait et c'est leur
priorité fermer toutes les centrales
nucléaires d'europe comme ils le disent
tous les jours au parlement européen
regardez ce à quoi conduire et la
thérapie de choc proposé par les
écologistes un désastre non seulement
économique non seulement sociale mais un
désastre climatique nous sommes l'un
famille politique qui défend le climat
parce que nous sommes la famille
politique qui défend les solutions pour
le climat et au parlement européen tous
les jours nous nous battons et nous
avons gagné cette année une bataille
absolument décisive avec notre
délégation pour pouvoir garantir que
nous serons capables d'investir pour
l'avenir dans cette énergie décarbonée
ce n'est pas nous qui disons que le
nucléaire est nécessaire c'est le giec
qui le dit nous sommes le parti de la
raison nous sommes le parti des
solutions et nous n'avons pas à rougir
devant ceux qui nous font croire que
nous ne sommes pas assez vert pour avoir
droit à la parole nous sommes ceux qui
défendent l'écologie réel l'écologie
authentique celle qui est réellement
fidèle à la cause de l'environnement que
nous avons le devoir de transmettre on
nous accuse parfois cher renault d'être
des conservateurs eh bien oui nous
savons que le premier devoir de la
politique c'est de transmettre aux
générations futures ce dont nous avons
hérité
leur transmettre la nature mais leur
transmettre aussi la culture et oui nous
voulons transmettre à ceux qui viendront
après nous cette culture française qui
fait de nous ce que nous sommes nous
n'avons pas à rougir devant une gauche
qui nous fait croire qu'elle défend les
déshérités alors qu'en réalité elle les
prive à l'école de ce qui pourrait les
faire grandir de ce qu'il pourrait leur
permettre de s'intégrer pleinement à la
société française si notre école est
dans une telle situation de
déliquescence ce n'est pas comme le dit
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
parce que la culture française et
raciste c'est parce que la culture
française n'est plus transmises c'est
pour cela que l'école française est
devenue inégalitaire et il n'y a qu'une
seule manière d'offrir aux plus modestes
d'offrir aux plus fragiles le succès
auquel ils ont droit c'est de leur
transmettre la plénitude de cet héritage
que nous avons reçue est que nous devons
leur offrir ne vous laissez pas
intimider par ce qui vous explique que
nous ne sommes pas assez sociaux nous
sommes ceux qui défendent les plus
défavorisés contrairement à son ministre
de l'éducation nationale qui a mis ses
propres enfants dans des écoles pour
ultra privilégiés nous savons que c'est
l'enseignement public qu'il faut sauver
que c'est l'école publique de la france
que nous voulons relever que nous
voulons reconstruire et que nous la
reconstruirons que sur la fierté qui
consiste à transmettre humblement ce que
nous avons reçues ne nous laissons pas
intimider et ce serait mon petit point
de désaccord avec ce que disait charles
tout à l'heure ne nous laissons pas
intimider par ce qui nous explique qu'il
ya des convictions qu'il serait ringarde
défendre oui moi je n'ai pas honte
d'avoir été un opposant de m taupe ira
quand elle prétendait changer la
civilisation française désolé je n'en ai
pas honte et je pense même que c'est
l'avenir je vais vous dire et je pense
même que notre combat d'hier n'a jamais
été autant d'actualité nous étions très
nombreux ici nous étions très nombreux
ici à porter le même message et nous
avions raison de le faire parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui nous expliquait
qu'il s'agissait seulement de changer le
mariage sont en train de nous dire qu'il
faut que les hommes soient en simple ce
qui nous explique à seulement qu'ils
s'agissait du mariage sont en train
comme au parlement européen nous a fait
voter il ya maintenant un an et une
résolution qui disait que messieurs vous
allez être ravis que les hommes doivent
pouvoir avoir le droit de faire
l'expérience de la grossesse voilà et
bien moi je vous dis chers amis que ce
monde est fou que le monde qu'on nous
promet est fou et que nous devons
défendre à temps et à contretemps
la sagesse l'equilibre l'intelligence la
justesse que nous devons défendre le
sens de l'expérience humaine et c'est la
grande question politique et aux
attentes mes chers amis vous êtes jeune
vous n'avez pas à rougir vous n'êtes pas
de vieux con quand vous dites que nous
avons le devoir de défendre ce qui fait
la fécondité de l'expérience humaine
tout entière et je crois que nous avons
au fond de nous mêmes cette certitude
profonde cette certitude profonde que
même les combats menés un jour à contre
courant peuvent devenir le secret nos
victoires futures lorsque ce qui nous
entoure se rendront compte que nous
avons eu raison nous avions eu raison
sur l'école nous avions eu raison sur le
nucléaire chez olivier nous avons eu
aussi raison de défendre un modèle de
société qui est authentiquement
respectueux de ce qui fait l'équilibré
de nos vies et je crois que ce combat là
n'a jamais été autant d'actualité
ne vous laissez pas intimider et cher
ami mon deuxième message tout simple et
très rapide c'est ne vous laissez pas
endormir
ne nous laissons pas endormir si nous
voulons défendre ses convictions nous
avons aussi le devoir de travailler nous
avons le devoir de revenir à la source
hier l'un d'entre vous m'a posé cette
question magnifique je veux m'engager en
politique
qu'est ce que vous me conseiller de lire
il n'y a pas de plus belle question
chers amis je partage avec vous c'est la
rentrée l'heure des bonnes résolutions
je partage avec vous cette intuition
tout simple le défi qui est devant nous
c'est de nous remettre au travail c'est
de recommencer à lire c'est de trouver
les moyens de défendre nos idées avec
des mots nouveaux c'est de trouver de
nouveaux moyens de parler à ceux qui
nous entourent vous en êtes tous les
témoins ici daniel le disait le constat
était partagée par tous ceux qui m'ont
précédé nous ne parlons plus assez aux
jeunes qui nous entoure nous ne parlons
plus assez cher jean luc aux urbains
nous ne parlons plus assez aux habitants
des grandes villes cher eric tu es le
seul à avoir réussi à emporter une
élection législative dans une ville de
plus de 100000 habitants pour notre
famille politique est bien ta victoire
doit être pour nous un exemple elle doit
nous permettre de comprendre ce que nous
avons à faire pour réussir à retrouver
le lien avec ce qui nous entoure
et
pour cela il faut nous remettre au
travail pour cela il faut nous remettre
au travail je relisais récemment le
discours magnifique de walter lippmann à
ses étudiants à la veille de la première
guerre mondiale à harvard walter
lippmann disait à ses étudiants nous
avons vécu trop longtemps sur un confort
illusoire nous avons tenu les bonnes
choses pour acquises désormais plus rien
l'état qui pour rien désormais pour
chaque droit auquel vous tenez il y a un
devoir qui vous attend pour chaque
espoir qui vous anime il y a une tâche à
accomplir
pour chacune des bonnes choses que vous
souhaitez préserver et que vous devez
aux vertus héroïques des générations
passées il vous faudra retrouver ces
mêmes vertus héroïques nous vivons dans
un moment où rien n'est plus acquis pour
rien chers amis et je crois qu'il faut
en avoir conscience il ne nous suffira
pas de répéter les mêmes slogans il ne
suffira pas de nous redire à nous mêmes
entre nous que nous sommes bien de
droite que oui nous sommes restés
fidèles à nos convictions il ne suffira
pas de nous donner à nous mêmes le
témoignage que nous n'avons pas dévié
pour que nous puissions demain retrouver
l'esprit et le coeur de ceux qui nous
entourent nous avons besoin de nous
remettre au travail nous avons besoin de
revenir à la source nous avons besoin de
reconstruire ce travail intellectuel de
reconstruire ce débat d'idées de
reconstruire cette vitalité qui nous
permettra demain de faire le débat et
non plus de le subir qui nous permettra
de créer la conversation est rompu de la
suivre et cher ami
chers amis je termine par là et bien je
vois mon dernier message est tout simple
mais là encore je sais que vous le
partagez déjà mon dernier message c'est
ne vous résignez jamais ne vous résignez
jamais
mais est-ce que j'ai besoin de vous le
dire en réalité ce message c'est vous
qui me le donne et ce matin c'est vous
qui par votre présence nous montrer que
vous savez qu'il ne faut pas baisser les
bras nous avons traversé des moments
tellement difficile et nous avons
traversé ensemble mais nous savons au
fond que healy a parfois et je le dis
très simplement de manière un peu direct
il y a parfois des victoires coupable il
y a parfois des victoires en deux et il
ya parfois des défaites plein donneurs
qui sont le point de départ d'une
reconstruction authentique de cette
reconstruction dont justement notre pays
a besoin il ya des victoires qui sont
obtenues au prix du mensonge il y a
parfois des postes mini des postes
ministériels qu'on gagne
avec simplement des reniements et en
payant de ses propres abandon l'espèce
d'apparence de pouvoir que l'on espère
obtenir il y à des victoires coupable et
il y à des défaites sur lesquels on peut
reconstruire pour l'avenir je ne dis pas
cela pour que nous nous habite fusion à
la défaite nous avons soif de victoire
et nous savons qu'il est possible de
gagner et nous savons que nous avons le
devoir de gagner parce que si nous
voulons que notre pays puisse enfin se
reconstruire il faudra que nous
puissions un jour assumer de nouveau des
responsabilités mais nous savons aussi
que ce qui compte d'abord ça n'est pas
d'arriver au pouvoir c'est tellement
facile d'arriver au pouvoir regarder
mc rognant regarder ce qui entoure
aujourd'hui le monde du pouvoir il
suffit de se trahir pour arriver dans un
ministère il suffit de se renier pour
espérer obtenir la petite récompense
temporaire nous savons que nous ne
voulons pas de cette victoire là nous
voulons d'une victoire fondée sur la
vérité et de ce point de vue là nous
avons le devoir de ne jamais nous
résigner chers amis il y a devant nous
des échéances très importantes
il ya devant nous des échéances très
importantes mais il ya aussi derrière
nous des succès extraordinaire des
succès sur lesquels nous pouvons
construire et je pense en particulier et
je voudrais dire mon immense admiration
et ma profonde reconnaissance à tous
ceux qui au cours de l'année passée ont
gagné ont conquis les succès qu'ils
peuvent faire que notre famille
politique aujourd'hui pèse dans le débat
parlementaire je voudrais dire mon
admiration à tous les députés qui ont
été créés lui l'an dernier qui ont été
élu l'an dernier malgré les petits
coupés géré livier
pierre aurélien mon admiration à tous
ceux qui ont mené ces combats
incroyablement difficile mon admiration
envers vous tous qui les avaient
entourées mon admiration envers chacun
de vous qui avez été parfois candidats
dans des circonscriptions très difficile
c'est sûr vos combats que nous pouvons
construire aujourd'hui je voudrais dire
mon admiration et ma reconnaissance à
tout le groupe parlementaire des
républicains au sénat qui est
aujourd'hui majoritaire et c'est sur
cette majorité que notre famille peut
construire son expérience
et je voudrais te le dire en particulier
à toi cher benoît qui est l'artisan du
travail de secondes toi qui tous les
jours
consiste constitue la pierre angulaire
de ce groupe sur lequel se construit le
travail que notre famille politique
aujourd'hui peut faire cher ami tu le
sais autour de toi pour que cette
coordination parlementaire nous
permettent de conquérir les victoires de
conquérir les succès qui permettront de
limiter les dégâts que le maquereau
nisme plus encore occasionné à la france
surtout cela chers amis nous pouvons
construire autant aujourd'hui surtout
cela ne pouvons construire les victoires
de demain à condition encore une fois de
ne pas baisser les bras une chose m'a
frappé dans cette année électorale et je
termine par là c'est la vitesse à
laquelle la situation évolue c'est la
vitesse à laquelle les perceptions
changent souvenez vous de la manière
dont les choses s'engager il y a encore
quelques mois quand nous étions en
septembre dernier à la veille de cette
année électorale qui aurait par exemple
parier sur le succès indéniable avec
lequel le rassemblement national a
terminé cette élection législative qui
aurait pensé que le rassemblement
national avait encore un avenir quand
nous étions en septembre dernier à la
veille de cette année d'élection
présidentielle
les choses changent extrêmement vite et
moi je suis convaincu que cette année en
particulier le vent va tourner très vite
parce que les français vont arriver à
l'heure des conséquences du maquereau
nisme parce que emmanuel macron lui même
va vivre cette année leur douloureuse
des conséquences fessenheim a été fermée
dans l'indifférence absolue mais lorsque
les français vont devoir subir des
coupures d'électricité je ne doute pas
une seule seconde qu'il se tourneront
vers monsieur macron pour lui demander
qui a fait fermer fessenheim
lorsque nous avons vécu le quoi qu'il en
coûte et le dérapage budgétaire
hallucinant que notre pays a connus
c'était dans l'indifférence absolue mais
je ne doute pas une seule seconde quand
les taux d'intérêt vont remonter et que
l'état ne pourra plus assumer ses
missions fondamentales
les français se tourneront vers monsieur
macro et lui demanderont qui à dépenser
notre argent les choses peuvent tourner
très vite à nous d'être prêts chers amis
est-ce que vous êtes prêts
[Musique]
alors je vous le dis très simplement si
vous êtes là aujourd'hui c'est le signe
le savons tous autour de vous avec
olivier avec bruno retailleau avec
chacun d'entre vous nous pouvons
reconstruire notre famille politique
tous ensemble quelle que soit la
diversité de nos sensibilités à la
veille de cette campagne je vous le dis
très simplement il n'y a aucune raison
que nous soyons divisée nous avons
toutes en commun nous pouvons faire de
ce moment qui nous attend l'occasion
d'une conversation utile pour
reconstruire depuis le début pour tout
refonder ensemble et ensemble j'en suis
sûr nous préparons avec vous avec vous
pour vous avec vous et pour les
générations futures les victoires de
notre famille politique dont notre pays
a tant besoin merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]